[Musique]
bonjour frédéric gauthier vous êtes
directeur de l'action sociale et
culturelle à la ville de
clayes-sous-bois la ville organise avec
l'association artisans et associés la
deuxième édition du festival courts
métrages quel est le but de ce festival
alors il ya un double objectif le
premier c'est tout simplement dans le
cadre de la politique culturelle de la
ville de travail éducation à l'image
auprès du jeune public et des cynophiles
et puis le deuxième objectif tourne
plutôt autour de rapprocher un petit peu
le court métrage des réalisateurs avec
le grand public puisque pendant cet
après midi il y aura toutes les heures
et demie coupure afin que le public
puisse échanger avec les réalisateurs
sur lors de la vente
donc ça se passe du côté de l'espace
noir et aux clayes-sous-bois donc deux
salles de cinéma classifiés art et essai
les courts métrages ne sont pas toujours
si conceptuel on en a parlé en préparant
les missions
on va regarder un petit extrait de bad
boys 2 enfants de choeur
[Musique]
ici fisher et tommy on se dirige vers
rodeo drive une poursuite ça faisait
longtemps
[Musique]
il faut rattraper d'autoroute où est-ce
qu'on est là je suis pas trop mais il ya
du soleil des palmiers c'est plutôt cool
ok et sur le gps est quoi
passez devant la bibliothèque parfait je
connais un raccourci près de la
bibliothèque sur wii qua non
m
[Musique]
la nouveauté cette année c'est aussi un
parent yvelinois d'exception tout à fait
avec la présence de mme agoh mabrouk
pardon elmeshri qui est le réalisateur
de jcvd
pour ceux qui connaissent aussi la série
maison close sur canal +
qu'effectivement nous donne une femme
fait l'honneur de venir ce demain pour
présider est à la fois aussi pour
présider le jury qui est composé de sept
personnes
je rappelle qu'il est né à versailles
qu'il a vécu aux clayes-sous-bois donc
c'est un heavy noir pur souche
complètement il avait une quinzaine
d'années sur le quartier nord de la
ville
il a aussi il vient aussi pour voir le
travail des scolaires qui a été fait et
ceux des jeunes ne de l'espace social
sémaphore aux clayes-sous-bois on
regarde un petit extrait de on dit quoi
[Musique]
je suis à ma dernière fois qu'on a fait
ouais bah il va je t'avais dit chagaf
que j'avais oublié ma pilule ce canton
histoire la légèreté pris la plume
lendemain non j'ai plus pensé après si
tu attends tu voulais absolument ce soir
là commence en moi je voulais absolument
c'est d'accord aussi pour qu'on fasse je
vais pas de faire un dessin chez
ensemble mais n'ont pas sérieuse mais tu
vois le met tous gosses on n'a que 19
ans mais dis moi j'aime ma famille dans
quartier de ça y'est on a merdé
à craindre
[Musique]
des jeunes talents peut-être des jeunes
comédiens qui débutent et qui parle d'un
thème un peu difficile mais grand public
tout comme cette deuxième édition est
placée sous le thème grand public
oui tout à fait parce qu'effectivement
nous aurons 22 courts métrages diffusés
20-20 fiction de souvenirs il y aura
aussi un dessin animé est un
documentaire parce que la première
édition était un peu plus particulière
tout à fait elle seule duré sur la
journée on sur la globalité de la
journée c'était un peu long donc on a
préféré réduire sur une demi-journée à
peu dans le microcosme aussi tout acier
hle assez grand public c'est ouvert à
tout le monde c'est entrée libre
donc effectivement tout le monde peut
venir sur une après-midi regarder ses
films et échanger les réalisateurs
puisqu'on nous arrêtons les diffusions
vers 20 heures
donc vous l'aviez dit tout à l'heure ça
dure une après-midi et toutes les heures
et demie il ya un échange avec les
réalisateurs c'est aussi ça le contact
vous les apportons aussi pour les
acteurs de pouvoir se rendre compte
comment leurs oeuvres est reçu par le
public et l'après midi se termine sur
alors on arrête de respawner est
effectivement à partir de 20h30
il y aura la remise des prix donc le
prix grand public
le prix du meilleur court métrage
décerné par mabrouk il y aura le prix du
meilleur comédien de la m meilleure
comédienne et du scénario et à la fin
c'est une on nous présenterons le
premier court métrage de mabrouk
le court métrage réalisé effectivement
par le centre social le sémaphore temps
aussi une école primaire de la ville et
de trois courts métrages présentés par
les membres du jury qui sont eux mêmes
réalisateurs qui fait partie du jury
aussi de alors de souvenirs
d'effectivement mabrouki président nous
aurons la nuit culturelle de la ville le
directeur de la communication un membre
de chez vous puisque vous êtes
partenaires et trois réalisateurs le
prix du public c'est une nouveauté cette
année
oui on a voulu d'être de développer
aussi c'est un tel interactivité ce qui
fait que tout l'après midi
le public pourra voter dans une urne
pour son film préféré par un système de
vote tout à fait il aura quel poids le
public dans cette décision du jury
100% d'accord sur le prix du public par
définition ça sera lui très bien vous
allez décerné quoi une palme d'or comme
à cannes en laminant tu te point
d'originalité pour le prix du meilleur
film ce sera un fauteuil de cinéma très
bien alors je rappelle que ce se passe
demain du côté de l'espace aux noirs et
aux clayes-sous-bois deuxième édition du
festival du court métrage je vous
remercie frédéric gauthier d'être venu
sur notre plateau foule merci